eric lauer yeah you talked about his
september it's been a pretty good one
two and away 109 earned run out he's
only allowed four home runs since the
end of may command has been very good
for him choking up on the bat
and he gets a breaking ball and drives
it out to right center field back toward
the gap and it hits at the base of the
wall nemo around second he's going to
try for three as kane retrieves it and
nemo easily into third base with a lead
off triple so nemo who's been crushing
lefties all year got a breaking ball in
the middle of the plate and picks up his
second triple of the season choose
francisco lindor
on the ground this will get a run home
adama's tough play long throw is in time
boy what a play by adamus the mets get
on the board first but adamus is able to
secure it out with an excellent play
deep in the hole at short
and a swing at him as he got him doesn't
lie the last one there's a lot of that
too partner
found the sweet spot the hole in baez is
bad
174th time javi baez has struck out this
year that is a bunch of swings and
misses on a fastball up out of the zone
and now the bases are loaded and the
inning continues for lauer two out for
mccann
got him
high fastball minimizing the damage
walking the tide rope early brewers
committed error a couple of hits only
one in now tyler mcgill on the mount for
the mets has been kind of a two-prong
season his first eleven starts the zra
just a tick over three and the last five
has been a struggle although he's mixed
in a good start here and there but his
bad ones have been bad
wong in the air right center field
that's on the barrel that is way back
there and it is gone
colton
his seventh lead off home run of the
year
and the brewers tie it quickly as bernie
hits the slide
colton wall gave it a weight back and
hook it on out of the ballpark into
right center
and narvaez went around on the slider
and that'll do it for the brewers in the
first home run by colton wong gets
milwaukee even as 1-1 after one
and down goes mcgill a strikeout for
lauer that is his third
nemo hammers one to left field
that's gonna stay in for yelich and a
three up three down inning that's more
like it flower a one two three inning
needed a quick one got a quick one one
ball two strikes on baez
he got him fastball inside corner
strikeout number four two up and two
down for lauer and he's retired six in a
row
so a man who's persevered hot ground
ball right to wall alonzo is out
three up and three down make it seventh
straight for eric lauer lead off man the
board courtesy of walk willie adams
flied to the warning track in deep right
field his first time up santa damas in
the air center field well hit nemo's
going back he leaps goodbye
two-run homer
william thomas
up into the toyota territory roars take
the lead on adamus's 23rd of the year
he's had a couple of near misses on this
home stand
a couple against the cardinals his first
hit bat tonight
flight out deep to right got that one
that time here's yelich now like it's
sends it deep left center
and that one's gone
christian yelich with a
left center field homer to make it four
to one brewers and how good must that
feel for yellitz to connect on one and
the first man to greet him there out of
the dugout is william thomas it's been a
while for christian his last home run
back in august the end of august
1-2 delivery half-swing and a strikeout
he's gone
that one way out of the strike zone
pilar was looking fastball that time and
he was really geared and by the time he
realized where it was going to be about
shoulder high too late
and a fly ball to right lauer will get
through five and maybe more he is
on the efficiency train here since the
first yell at you homer is last time up
yeah it's down the left field line
slicing and it's down
fair ball
yelling on his way to second now on his
way to third
throw comes in late yeah
and
nothing better garcia fielder's choice
line drive to right
fly ball right center yell at will tag
nemo makes the catch fires one all the
way in yeltsin's it easily
and the brewers add to their lead five
to one milwaukee
sac flight at rbi for abi garcia after a
39 pitch first inning he's stranded the
bases loaded one run scored he has only
given up two hits
and
strikes out baez for the third time
tonight much to the delight of the fans
here at american family field
and a swing at a miss make it seven k's
for eric lauer and that time of slider
not exactly where you how you draw it up
but he'll take it
first ball swinging
got him in the air left center yelts
will make the call and the catch
and a one two three sixth for eric lauer
what a job tonight
lauer picks up his eighth strikeout he's
got five in a row now 18 out of his last
19 retired
and he gets a strikeout how about it
that's nine
for eric lauer nine k's got him on a
slider yeah back-to-back strikeouts for
eric with the slider nine k's for lauer
matches a career best
bouncing ball adava it's gonna be a
tough play here no play not with the
speeding mcneil running that'll be a
base hit the first hit for the met since
the first inning well lauer's going to
get a big hand he'll walk off this mound
to a standing ovation his council is
going to take the ball what a
performance tonight six and two-thirds
and listen to this crowd as lauer exits
and with two outs and a pinch hitter
jose peraza it is brent suter
first ball swinging
fly ball to center field and it took one
pitch couldn't even get it in one call
one pitch
that's all
thus the mets are down to their final
line of the night
in the air to center field hit well back
is kane
at the track makes the play ball game
over and the brewers win the brewers
beat the mets 5-1 and a magic number of
two